we are in a completely unprecedented
environment and we've been in that
environment for so long it's actually
quite easy to forget that it is quite
mad zero interest rates and the amount
of money that's flooded through the
system in the last few years moving away
from that albeit in very very slow moves
it's completely different to a move from
two and a half to three or three and a
half to two for it in interest rates
it's completely different you can look
it from the perspective of the base
effect because we've actually never come
from zero before so this is completely
unknown in fact Japan tried it and
didn't get very far and ended up going
back so there's that argument the
counter-argument that's a little bit is
to say well and you'll mention the
strength of the US economy is actually
say well actually that's why in many
ways where we are is inappropriate for
where the economy is today so yes it's
only from yes it's a huge step from zero
to maybe 25 basis points but it's a step
that needs to happen to get you away
from something that arguably is just not
appropriate for an economy that has
unemployment at five percent instead of
painting a ten percent
charlie is the curious one it's
obviously firing away two biggest
economy in this part of the world but
I'm let's say it's probably in good
order it can handle at least you know a
Fed rate hike for sure that's because
even with downward pressure on do you
want they have around three and a half
trillion in reserves to to shored up so
they can intervene for quite some time
and of course there's issue of local
currency denominated debt the China do
high of a significant volume of US
dollar debt however there's a feeling
they think they can manage that it's not
on the same scale as in terms of blogs
of Malaysia Indonesia half so the
overall sense is China can handle a fake
tightening this needs Akane you know you
think they are there's a lot of people
who would argue now that you know the UK
MPC doesn't want to go in till after the
Fed does but while we debate the
arguments for the Fed raising rates we
sit there in amazement that the
unemployment rate goes down from a
percent every year and wage growth
floats around two percent without really
going anywhere here we have really clear
evidence that labor market tightness is
feeding into higher wage growth and
frankly we ought to get on with it and
raise rates
it's very obvious in from an ECB
standpoint that the risks to the
downside are now a lot more severe than
there were only a couple of months ago
and the December numbers when you see
them being published their new staff
projections are going to be again a much
lower so the gap of projected inflation
to insulin to the target is getting me
even wider and we think that will prompt
the Governing Council to deliver
additional system is by extending QE we
thought it would be a spring of next
year we brought it forward to end of
this year mainly because we think that
we have some spare capacity issues and
certainly was the euro the ways been
trading I think that the central bank
needs to deliver additional policies to
minister